From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, this is Billy Bud.
Today is Wednesday, March 13, 2013.
My name is Dr. John Dittmer and I am here in Tchula, Mississippi with the videographer John Bishop.
To interview Rosie Head, a leading civil rights activist in the Holmes County Mississippi Movement.
This interview will become part of the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture in Washington, DC.
Ms. Hatt, we're delighted to have you here today and we thank you for taking the time to talk with us.
I'd like to begin by asking you about your family.
Were you born and raised in Holmes County?
I was born in Holmes County.
And, tell us what were your parents' parents' duties for living?
My dad was a carpenter and a sharecropper.
And we worked in the cat and field, corn fields.
And the gardener said we called truck patches, raised all our foos.
And we had cows, horses, news, chickens, and hogs.
A real farm, then.
Did you have brothers and sisters?
I had two brothers and seven sisters.
And where are you on that chain?
I'm about the sixth.
And you have a number of members of your family.
You want to wait till the train goes on.
You don't immediately.
Yeah, I'm just going.
Okay, but we're back.
So your family, your father was a carpenter.
What did he do?
Build houses?
Build houses.
And did he have a crew who was he working with?
Mostly he worked by himself during that time.
Later on in life, he started to work with another guy that was friend of his, Mr. Horton.
We interviewed Mr. Bruce the other day.
He was talking about the work that he was doing as a carpenter.
Did your father apprentice himself to anyone?
Or was he just naturally talented there?
I was just naturally.
What was it like to grow up in this town?
It was, I grew up in Lexington.
I was six years old when I left Lexington.
And I moved to Greenwood.
My father had him to, if I had to farm on a plantation on my own,
to keep their houses up.
And I lived in Greenwood about ten years.
Okay, well tell us about Greenwood.
What was it, what was it, the big change from Lexington?
It was, it was.
But we lived out in the country.
And every once in a while we'd get to go to town.
And it was exciting to go and see all the things going on in Greenwood.
And mostly we worked out on the farm, picking and chopping cotton.
And we did, we were old enough to go in the fields.
We were babysitting the younger children.
And we started, I started working in the fields when I was seven years old.
You were chopping and picking with your hands up?
Yes, I'd rather be, I would be the crowd, be sitting in the house, maybe sitting.
So I proved that I could do it.
So what was the real family affair of that?
It was.
Tell us about going to school.
I went to the first year, when I was six years old, I didn't get to go to school.
I was supposed to go to a school called Hickory Springs in Lexington.
But you had to walk across a creek to get to the school.
And I was too little to go.
So I had to stay home.
And when we moved to Greenwood, just before I turned seven.
And I started to school in that January.
And we walked to school about five Mileston.
And when I was about ten, they started giving us buses.
So we still had to walk about two, three Mileston to the bus stop.
Oh, that's quite a sacrifice to make for an education.
Most of the young kids today wouldn't know what to do.
What is the situation like that?
Yeah, we walked.
We went to a school that was a church.
And it was just the one room.
All the grades pre-premise through eighth grade was in that school.
How many teachers did you have?
One teacher.
One teacher for all eighth grades.
And what were your favorite subjects?
I always loved reading.
The church was an important part of the community.
Was it your family as well?
It was.
I remember we said, have to get up and walk to the Sunday school with every Sunday morning.
And regular service would be one Sunday of my, but Sunday school was every Sunday.
And if it was like during the summer when it was hot, the dust was like up here on the legs.
And it was real hot.
We had to carry our shoes in our hands and carry our wet cloth so that when we get to church,
we could wash out legs and feed and put our socks on shoes like that.
Because you're wearing your Sunday best?
Yes.
Yeah.
Well, we're going to be talking about civil rights and the racial situation in Mississippi.
What was segregation?
Were you aware of segregation when you were in Greenwood?
Oh, yes.
Very much so.
My mom cooked for the plantation owner.
And the younger children, there were three of us.
There was two little, that first to go to the fields.
And we had to walk across with her to the plantation owner's house.
And I remember we had this little girl, her name was Corinne,
And my mom had to call her Miss Corrine.
I remember she could play out with us, but we couldn't come in the house,
where she could play outside with her.
And you had an understanding of what was going on now,
or did you have to be told that there are certain things you couldn't do?
Then we knew, because my family was a can that talked at home to all of the children
to make sure they knew what the rules for our family was and what we couldn't do.
So we would tell her how to play, so we could do what we couldn't do.
Was the plantation owner fair in terms of settlement?
Oh, no, I can remember.
We would farm that land, and we would pick, we could pick at least a bale kind of day.
We would pick some time, we would work on Saturday morning,
and we would pick out six bales of cotton.
And at the end of the year, like the day before Christmas,
they would, every farmer would be called in to the office of the plantation owner.
And we would have picked out whether we were supposed to get half of what we would make on the farm.
And we would pick some 75 to 80 bales of cotton a year.
And I can remember every time my dad would come back home,
they would like you to walk up to the barn or the shop where they paid off,
what they call you, and say, if you made any money.
And my dad would always come back and when he would get back home,
we always waited up for him, and he said, I'm going to take his head off.
And he always called my mom, baby.
And he just said, baby, we came out in the hole again.
And he said that man, you said he could just hear me every time he would go in
would say, well, Robert, I'm sorry, but you didn't clear nothing, you came out in the hole.
Did they hurt issue and everything? Was there a company store?
Did they get a job?
There was a company store, and they gave us, it was what, 12 of us.
And they gave us $35 a month to get that much from the store.
And so it was pretty much the same situation that had been going on for almost a hundred years then.
Yeah, well, as a kid, what was your reaction when you saw that you had been cheated?
Your family and then cheated?
It was a hurting thing, everybody knew that that's the time we looked forward to Christmas
and we would get something toys or something new.
But they made sure you get food and stuff like that, you could go to the store and get that.
And I remember my mom used to make dolls for us, like the sacks that you buy, flour in.
And she would make our clothes for little flour sacks and meal sacks.
And she would make dolls for us.
And we would find our dolls and apple and our orange and some nuts raising.
And I can remember that so well, they were the best raisins I've ever.
Every Christmas, and you could smell it all over the house, because when they bring it in,
they would put it in the closet so nobody would mess with it until the right time.
And that's what we would look forward to.
So your folks tried to give you as normal a childhood as a good service?
They did.
But there was a lot going on then.
You had, of course, the lynching a murder of Emmett Till.
Yes.
And he was about your age, what?
I tell us about it.
You're learning about it and what your conversations in the family and what it is all mean.
I can remember.
We lived in this house that was across behind the boss, the plantation on this house across the living.
And we had a radio, we had TV then, we had a radio.
And we heard it on the radio where my mom heard she was cooking and she heard it and she called everybody and said,
and she called it mining right across from where he was at this store.
I went to school there.
That's the school I went to.
We'd walk over across the railroad to that store every day.
And we had some pennies and nickels.
We'd walk over there.
She was in the wild for (Carolyn) Bryant + Roy Bryant.
Mrs. (Carolyn) Bryant + Roy Bryant, Mrs. (Carolyn) Bryant + Roy Bryant.
She was waiting for him for (Carolyn) Bryant + Roy Bryant.
What kind of a person was?
She was so sad when we went to the store.
She was thinking, do you going to try to pick up something or something like that?
She would make sure you stay in one side and wait your turn and come and spend your penny or nickel or whatever.
She was afraid you'd steal from her.
Not a nice person.
Did you know in the town, the town that you were staying with?
No, I didn't really know that.
There was a school bus there when we started getting bus.
I lived near Greenwood about a mile out of Greenwood.
And mine is about 8 to 10 Mileston.
We went on school bus up there.
I didn't know any people that pay my money.
I talked with a number of civil rights workers.
And they said, you know, the pill was about their age.
They realized that it could be them.
Did the folks give you any special instructions after that?
There was no, you know, just staying out place and doing what they tell us to do.
And now, they, all my dad always said that God was going to take care of us.
And we do the right thing.
And we just did what he asked us to do.
And we said it was right for us to do.
So you stayed out of trouble for a while then.
Until you started causing something.
Yes.
So, after in the late 1950s, you were what, teenager?
What were you doing then?
I was still suffering and peaking cat.
And then my dad finally saved up enough money to buy a new car.
And he was just a seven, she really brand new.
And you know how you had to pay something down.
And the boss had, he had gotten where he wanted the men to come and work.
But he wouldn't let them come in his office to pick up the paycheck.
He would ask them to send their wives to pick up the paycheck.
But my dad, my mom said he tried to talk to the black women.
He liked black women, the way he wanted to use them.
But my dad refused to let my mom go and pick his shake up.
And he would have better get it.
And he refused to give it to him.
And told him, he asked him for it.
He had laid his keys down on the counter.
The man picked his keys up and he told him he wouldn't get his car, his keys are his check.
And he told him, it was all right, if that's what you want to do.
But he won't need to be paying him a check anymore because he wouldn't be there.
But he thought he had to check the keys and he thought he couldn't leave.
So, but he had a second pair of keys and all.
And we left that night.
We left that plantation and moved to Chua.
I had an aunt living down in Tchula,
And we moved there.
The guy where we could in the car and moved down there in the neighborhood kept the furniture.
But I understand that he scared her the next morning.
And she just gave up the furniture to him.
She had it.
So we had to start all over again then.
Did they try to get you back?
Let's say you owe them money already.
He tried to get the car away from us.
But it was, you know, then they had contact with where they could talk to this farmer, this person.
And they stopped you from getting work there, getting in the account of money.
So my dad lost a car and that was his way of getting around and making money and doing carbon award.
And that was, that was how I fought.
Was it really, like, to be a weight in the plantation and in Chua, Chua?
Because most of the people, black people around Chua, that project had been given to people then down in Mileston.
And we were able to get one of those houses.
And did you farm there?
We did.
Certain stances were better?
My sister's better.
And well then what happened?
What were you, you were in Tchula now?
How old are you?
Oh, I was 17.
And I kept, there were lots of people around that you could go and chop and pick cotton and buy the day.
And I did bed for about six, seven years of pick cotton and chop for a dollar and 50 cents a day.
And pick cotton and for a dollar a hundred.
And I could pick about 500 a day and that was just...
Now did that money go all to the family or did you have some of them?
That's it had to go to the family.
So everybody was pitching in?
So when did you go out on your own?
For India.
In 1964, so it's three and 64.
We started talking together with some people from Greenwood about the movement that different people were coming into Mississippi to help people learn to register the vote.
So we started going to Greenwood like certain nights they would have meetings, certain days they would have meetings there.
We started going there until we got a young man to come to Tchula.
And we started having the meetings out there.
We had a freedom school and one of the churches in that area let us use the church to have our meetings and everything.
Let me back up a little bit.
And because the question I'm always asking is what motivates you to become involved in the civil rights movement?
Why? Because not very many people did early on.
Especially you were probably one of the first around here, right?
Yes.
You heard about the meetings in Greenwood and then did several of you go?
Yes, it had. We've been talking about it since I've heard my dad and other people talking since the end of the year about we're going to have to do something.
It just kept not doing anything.
And finally it just came to the point where they found something that could help.
And they would tell us all about it.
And I just got interested. It was just like it was a way I knew what the people there was in charge.
I knew what they thought of us and how they were treating us.
And I just knew that was a better way.
And just went out there hoping it was clean.
So what, do you remember, did you first go to a meeting in Greenwood in 62 or what?
Who were the SNCC people who were?
John Ball.
And I can't miss in this fellow name. He was a blocker.
He was a sound blocker, yes.
Stokely Carmichael, Bob Moses, and Lawrence Guyot.
There's a lot of people, different people than I'm not getting their names.
That sort of (Willie Wazir) Peacock, I think.
Yes, probably.
And Hollis Watkins.
Hollis is still going strong.
Yes he is. Good name.
So you went to the meetings and tell me about a typical meeting.
What went on in the meeting?
We would just sit around and talk about the things that
was unfair to black people as like the segregated places, the schools,
and the different places like the courthouse, and the water fountain,
and things around the bathroom, restaurants, and things that we couldn't use.
We talked about how we were second class citizens, but we were having to pay taxes
like first class citizens.
And we talked about things that could be available to us.
And we just had to pay after getting it.
And we talked about how we had to do to get registered to vote,
and that's where the power was.
We could get some of the things that we needed if we were first class citizens
and that would make us first class citizens.
Did you work in the voter registration campaign in Greenwood,
or did you wait till it came here?
I did you.
I believe it was John Ball.
He was a do-it-all.
He John Ball came to Holmes County.
And of course, there's the first work team.
Were you aware of what was going on then?
Yes.
The Mileston was very close.
Oh really?
The mission is kind of the assistance.
They were all close people.
We went to church together.
Miss Carnegie was real, after real early.
She was real.
Yeah, what's she talking about?
She was real warrior.
Something else, yes you were.
So what about the other people who were Carpenterinbo was the name that comes up.
Tell me about Terinbo.
That's the Terinbo.
There's just one type of Terinbo.
He was fearless.
He would get up in the media.
And when he started talking to everybody, we'll catch on.
He would just talk and tell all the things that the people had been doing to black people.
And he would tell them, actually they want to have that going on all the ways that you want to do something about it.
And he would get people all stereotyphing.
They'd be ready to go.
And if a group, however many of them, they say they're going to be there in the morning and we're going,
that's what they would do.
Everybody would be ready to go.
You hear lots of Turnbow stories.
I heard one from Josephine Disparti.
Do you remember her?
Yes, yes.
She was the nurse that she lived with Terinbo.
Right.
Yeah.
She was saying that there was one meeting where there were all kinds of oppositions.
And the one he was doing so at some point he gets out of his pistol and he's going to take a little sip of his bowl.
Yes, he did.
He did.
He just, whatever he believed in and whatever he stood for, he did his whole heart and the 100%.
He went scared of nobody.
And he predicted all the things that we see now.
He predicted all the things he used to come by my house and just sit and talk.
After things had kind of quieted down some for years.
He was getting older and he would tell me about what they'd expect.
He said, I'll be gone.
But he told me how many prisons was going up.
And all that young black boys was going to be in those prisons.
He saw that.
He saw it.
And it happened.
Where are the things?
The things was quiet.
Kind of real man of man.
And he thought he had to think things out completely before he would do anything.
But he was always willing to do what he could.
And he would try to help the rest of them to plan.
So if there was something going on that he thought everybody might get locked up.
He and a couple of other guys would stay back so that they could be there to help get them out of jail if they got locked up.
So he was kind of a quiet person.
But he was always willing to do things.
A good farmer.
So his personality was sort of the opposite of Mr. Hartman Turnbow.
Just the opposite.
And yet they were both leaders in that sense.
What about statewide leaders?
Did you go to meetings where Medgar Evers spoke?
I did.
Yeah.
And when you heard the news that he had been assassinated, what was going through?
It was like a family member.
It had been killed.
Because we had been used to here and away off where they would lynch people.
And they would burn their houses down, take over families.
This guy told me I was working in the cat field, picking cat, and he told me about this white farmer head.
Every time he, like he was being the house with his family, if it's one of the time they would do not do anything then.
He said that that was the worst thing I've ever heard.
He said that this farmer would come in his house and he would have to leave home and let him stay there and have his way with his wife.
And he couldn't come back until he stayed with the time for him to come back.
It's like Basin's flavor.
But there was now a woman going on to do something about the air in memory.
Someone was here around the mushroom.
He came the whole time.
Well let's talk a little bit about the Council of Federated Organizations.
And we'll move up.
I want to get into politics because you were very active there.
But there was, for example, the Freedom vote in the fall of 63,
where Aaron Henry and Ed King were running.
And you've had a big campaign for a a mock election this to prove to the world that this is the big election vote given the chance.
Were you active in that campaign?
Yes, I was.
Tell us about what you did.
I went around canvassing the communities to get people, make sure people understood what the a mock election.
And it was about how important it was to get out and come out and vote.
And help out in the schools with the trained people what to do and how to do it.
They come out and there was in kind of confrontation with the white folk.
They would know what to do and not to get in the trouble.
And we went all over Holmes County, all out in the heels, legs of the party, and do rent.
And we are to get people to come out and register and try to vote.
So I'm afraid even with the mock election to take the vote?
Some are afraid because they were living in this plantation on this house that they were thinking.
We would never place to live.
Some people got put off the plantations and we had to find places where I was to live.
And then there were people from the north that were sitting food and clothing and mining down.
And we would help them out that way.
But I remember several houses we had gone to.
And we were then talking about head start trying to get head start.
And we had to go to each house whether they accept us or not.
And we would go to the white farm with houses.
And they would always make you know you got to go to the back door.
So they would either come out and curse you out.
I'll say no you get that you couldn't go but they just say you can get out of my property and curse you out.
And that was it.
You were canvassing all the houses and talking about head start.
It was supposed to be an integrated program.
We had to do that to be able to get federal money.
But for the election we just had to make sure we got everybody out and found out who needed a ride to come to vote in the mock election.
Where were the polling places for the mock election?
In Thornton and in Mileston.
They were like all over the county.
Were they in Barberjob, Beauty Barber?
And then anybody had a place that had a place in the youth.
So the vote set a message.
But still at this time despite years of organizing why the white supremacists still have the upper hand.
And the federal government wasn't really that interested in what was going on.
It didn't seem to be interested.
And the Ku Klux Klan had revived.
Was there any clan activity in Holmes County?
Oh yes. I can remember there were about six of us.
We called it the Holmes County Community Center that Frian came down from California and deals for us.
And we would all be there working late at night trying to get out of newsletters and get things ready to put in the mail for the next day.
And several nights we would be just, there was a little sleeping quarters upstairs there.
And we would be just getting settled down and we would hear the trucks out there making, turning around, around in the yard in front of the building.
And then they would shoot up in there.
And when we hear that, you know, it was just scared of us there.
And we would go and try to call some of the men to come.
And they would just continue.
They would be shouting all kinds of language out at us and telling us to get out of that and what they would do to us.
And by the time they see, we would like to send a set across railroad track.
And we could see every car that turned off.
By the time they see somebody coming that way, they would set the crawls out there and get back in the truck.
And then like the crawls would shoot up in there and leave.
And all intimidation.
So you really were living with a fear of going on?
All the time, even like when I would go home, I would, the adults would take turns sitting up watching the makes you.
Of course, they were famous for throwing those what he called cocktails.
Yeah, they would throw them in people's houses.
How did you overcome your fear?
Just praying and knowing that it was nothing else to do, you couldn't go back.
Well, because things seemed to be still in the hands of the White Power structure without any assistance from outside,
there was a decision made to have a summer project in 1964, bringing hundreds of students down to the North,
most of whom turned out to be white, to really shine the spotlight on Mississippi.
And to get the nation outraged about what was going on.
And they'll be working in freedom schools, voter registration, the new Freedom Democratic Party, which we'll be talking about.
And also in community centers.
There were, they are, I read where there are about 30 Freedom Summer volunteers in Holmes County.
Tell us about what Freedom Summer was like here in your role.
It was like I spent most of my almost 24 hours a day in that deal.
And with those people doing whatever it was to do, we would just be planning the way who was going where
and what we had to do to get people to come out and learn how to go and try to register.
And we would all get together and get in no call, whatever call we could find and go around campus in the community.
That was the most we did, we were campus to get people out.
And we would have meetings in different communities to talk to people so that they would understand and wouldn't be scared to come out.
And we let them know that we all would be in it together, whatever happened, we was going to help them out of it.
They didn't have a place to stay, that's what we were going to be able to help them when we were at them.
So the volunteers were staying with local people?
Local people, yes.
How did Wines Free Act, this invasion as they go?
Sometimes we would go downtown or some in the public place and they would just stand around just like, you know, they would be talking screaming out,
you know, niggas, they had to do anything and calling them niggas levels.
I never forget, we went to, we walked from Valley State from over here to being to Jackson.
And there were people who left to that railroad to go down the state street.
There were people on those railroads up on those box cars and they were throwing big rocks down there.
They were just doing it enough for it not to hit you, but they wouldn't know if it was going to hit you.
And I had gone, they had everything and they were calling us some of everything and the police men and highway patrol were right there, but they didn't say it was.
Was this during a murder of the parks?
Yes, yes.
Were there any extreme racial incidents in Holmes County during Freedom Summer?
Do you remember people playing arresting them?
Yes, that was Sam House.
He got arrested several times.
They had this black guy in Lexington, we call him Fett.
He would, if they just walked down the streets, he would pick him up and put him into here.
And there was a lot of time that they got, we were marching and they would come out upset about it.
We would be marching because we would boycott and some stores out there.
And there was a time when this lady that they had taken her bag, she would not leave and just pull her down and expose her old body to everybody.
One of the things that was going on that summer, I mean, Holmes County was unique in many ways in terms of the Civil Rights Movement.
But a guy from California named Abe Osheroff came down to build the Mileston Community Center and tell us about what that was like from your ad seeing these strange folks out there going to work.
We couldn't believe it.
Someone would come and give us a whole new bill and like, my dad helped to build the center and he abled the good man and a real kind hearted.
He looked big and seriously, but he was a real kind hearted man.
We got to be real good friends.
Seeing that Bill and go up, people would come from all over the county and just stand around and watch things being done.
And when the building the guy finished with the building they couldn't get the gas company to put gas in, they couldn't get a telephone.
And we had to have wood heaters that we put up in the building they said, I think they were so much dope.
And they did some of everything to scare us out of there.
They were right from the highway over there. You probably came up through Mileston.
They had to come across the railroad to get over there and they would keep one or two highway patrol and sit in there stopping everybody to come through so that they let people know not to try to come through because you would get a ticket and get your license taken away from them.
So in the same way, people going to Tougaloo sometimes and they can stop saying, go move there.
That fall, a couple of new people came to town, Henry and Sue and Lorenzi.
Yes.
They lived in the center for a little while.
They talk about Sue + Henry then when I'm going to talk about your work at the center.
Sue + Henry, when they came in, they were different for sure whether it was going to stay here.
And they got to know some of the people there and realized what we had and what we needed then they decided to stay.
And everybody kind of took a liking to Sue + Henry.
Everybody would all come out to the center every day just to talk to Henry and Sue.
And they were always Henry was the one that looked like he had all of them out of the head and asked us everything he came up with.
He had asked me about working in the center, managing the community center when they were getting ready to leave.
I was telling them I didn't have no skills for that.
I didn't know how I would do anything like that.
And he was telling me all the things that I had that I didn't know if he went down the line telling me about what I had did for him since he had been there.
And he was telling me that I always told me I need to write a book.
And I never did.
Henry was a good man.
We always tried to help the Arnold off.
He felt needed to the mostly.
He would let it be known that these other people you need to be looking to do things for and try to encourage them.
But Henry and Sue did a lot to organize our community and all over the county.
They finally eventually moved over in Lexington.
But they were always coming back over and doing things to keep people together.
And he asked you to run the center and you did.
Now I want you to spend a little bit of time talking about your work there.
Because lots of people read about community centers but they don't have the following idea of what their purpose was.
So tell us about the milestone center and what services it provided and what kind of work you were doing.
The main purpose of the center was to have a place for people to meet and to come together and talk about their problems of what they probably were in the county
or what we could do to make it better.
And it was like what I did was to keep all the records of everything they went on in the area in the county.
And I was like to take all the messages coming in from wherever, even out of the state and everywhere.
And sending newsletters out.
And that was about four other young women working with me.
And I was just in charge of making sure that everything, there was a record kept for everything.
And that everything was in the center that needed to be there, everything that we needed to keep to be on and running was there.
I had, I would call people and inform them about meetings of whatever was going on across the county.
I would get out newsletters and also send notices to people that let them know things that were going on in the county.
What was the cost of the county?
Well, that was like you spoke of Josephine Disparti and there was another lady.
Her name was Helen, I believe.
Helen Richardson?
And Helen, you mean there was another guy on the way.
And they came first just in the center they would help out.
They gave people physical exams and everything and whatever medical services they could bring that they did.
And we found a way to get a little room built for the clinic.
And they started letting people come from all over the county just like a regular doctor's office.
And they stayed there.
At least I know all that summer.
And they would come back once in a while but they offered medical services to the county.
And there were the medical committee for human rights organization running into them.
Young doctor named Albert Versailles.
I knew him well.
In fact he used to stay in touch with me a lot.
Yes.
But I think people, movement, comprehensive community health centers which provide health care to over 30 million Americans now that all started in that little clinic in milestone.
From there they got the idea to expand and open health centers here in America.
How do they operate?
There are several medical clinics for their school out there.
There was a name for this doctor, a renacy maler.
And they had those clinics in a lot of times.
And they offered services to people they can't afford regular doctors.
They free-service to some people and some people you pay as you're able to.
So was health care improved around here from the time that you were sick on the plantation?
What did you do?
Take home remedies.
Did you ever see a doctor?
I had never seen a doctor until I had my first child.
Or been in a hospital?
Never.
And the rest of your family did they?
Because they'd have to take.
And my mom had all of us at home.
And there were no black doctors in the county.
No.
So there have been some changes there.
Other, you're far too modest about your work in the center.
I have something here that says you handle day-to-day center programs for kids.
A kindergarten?
Oh, yeah.
I'm thinking of getting about his idea.
We did the two years before we got federal money we had.
We had decided that we wanted to open a school for kindergarten.
We didn't have a kindergarten at the time.
And they were kindergarten age children.
So with the help of Sue + Henry, we set up a makeshift school for children to come
and we went around in Kansas to see what children we could get to come.
And we had Abe also gave us a truck when we went to build a center.
And we could finally learn how to drive it well enough that we would go around and pick up all the children
and bring them to school and keep them there.
I'm telling them 330 in the evening.
We would feed them.
In the morning time we would have stuff like grits, oatmeal, milk and cookies or whatever we could get.
And the different farmers would give us things, different items to help out.
And they would give us money for kids or either they would give us kids, put kids in the truck from their farming kids.
And we would go around and pick the children up and bring them back.
And we would do all kind of things.
We made clothes for them.
We had sewing machines and I assisted me.
We had a soul of this and we made clothes for all the children.
And we would go through all kind of activities.
We had farmers to come out and play around and quit.
And we just did everything that you were doing at school with the help of Sue + Henry.
Now this was before he had started.
He was basically everything.
And sometimes I think it was better then because you could do what you wanted to have all these rules.
Did that reinforce the gun?
It was a good problem for people.
Everybody was children now.
Sometimes they come by and they won the boy I never forget.
We all called him short.
And he said, the first day he came to school and he cried so hard not to come.
And we came and picked him up anyway.
And he went back on with his shoulders.
Grandma, that's the best school in the world.
Because they will feed you three meals every day you go to school.
And then they'll let you lay down and go to sleep.
And still bring you back home.
And he said he told me he'll never forget that.
And he said, I'm going to go with him and rest of the life.
And he said every time he goes somewhere they start talking.
And some people talk about their first teachers.
And he would go back and call my name and think about all the times.
That when he was scared and nervous I would let him lay on my lap and rock him in the little rock.
And he said, I was at home.
I had two grandbots.
That was a good problem.
I want to talk about your work in Head Start a little later.
But now let's like to switch to another major area of your concern and activity.
And that is voting in elections.
And what you have is a county that has majority black, very few blacks voting.
And this you have we talked about trying to register in April of 1963.
And then in 1965 the voting rights act was passed.
And federal registrars came in.
And how did you take advantage of this?
The federal registrars came and we had tried to go out and register.
And we were blocked from that.
In fact, we were taking a lot of people out all the time.
And when I first went out there were five of us winning.
And when we went up to the courthouse and the sheriff knew that we were there,
all his debuts just came out with the dogs and the clubs and the guns and everything.
And I was real nervous because I'm afraid of dogs.
They would walk right along the side.
And let the dog be between them and you.
And then when they go, they'd pull them back just a little bit, but they would come back again.
I never forget when I went, when I finally went in,
they put me in a little room like a closet with a little desk in it.
They closed the door.
And I'd been in there by now.
And I had finished, been finished with that feeling out the paper.
I tried to open the door and when I touched the door knob, I heard the dog growling.
I said, oh my god.
Every time I was touched the door, he was proud.
So they had left him there, guarding the door.
And it was about four hours later when they came and let me out.
And I was scared to death.
So you were held as a prisoner?
Because I was thinking if I come out, you'd definitely going to take me.
That's the story I've never heard of.
All kinds of intimidation.
That's what they do.
And the Chancellor Clerk had said to me, now I know you know that he knew my grandparent.
I've known your people for years and years and I know you know better.
What are you doing out here anyway?
And so I told him what I wanted.
And he said, you go home and do like your mom and your grandmom did.
You don't need to come out here.
And they were all waiting for black folk.
That's the way they did.
All of us, they went for a later day when we were mean.
And we were able to go back a second day for some of us.
And we all went together because we knew how it was.
But they never told us that we had passed the test until the federal regressive came.
And they found the records and everything.
And they had passed the test until the next year.
And they finally told us that we had passed the same, which time we had gone out there.
But they did, you passed it, but they didn't tell us.
They didn't tell us.
They were supposed to send you a letter or a notify you that they didn't tell us.
So it really took real courage before the voting rights act.
I always tried to register.
And then the voting rights act is passed and the federal registrar has come in.
And it's a lot easier, isn't it?
And now how did you get folks who had been afraid to vote to register before saying it's okay now?
What did you do to get them to the registrar?
They started it after they saw so many people.
And then the main thing was when they started to see that there were houses available for them.
And they get put out the plantation.
They were afraid of not having a place to live.
And so other people gone.
Sometimes we would just get truckloads of people all in the back of the truck and take them out there.
And you had to take them.
Most people wouldn't just go on their own.
Somebody had to be with them, just like they just think that they had protection.
And it took a lot of talking.
A lot of people said they were gone and didn't have a long time.
And they all got a little better.
And they knew that everybody was doing it.
And if I hadn't started coming out.
One of the things that it was notable, I think, throughout the state.
And throughout the South is that at the beginning, the early stages of the civil rights movement,
black professionals, the teachers and preachers were not around very much worth it.
Why was that?
I think most of them thought that they stood in good with their white folk.
And they didn't want them to think they were doing that because they were telling them that they were some crazy white folks coming in here.
Some eyesight agitators and educated people.
And people like them weren't supposed to be.
But I think they were mostly scared and they were good at it.
They had behind some of the teachers thinking they would lose their job.
Because Bernice Montgomery is from the beginning.
She came down with us and she would come to my house and put all the meetings.
She was a teacher.
It's sort of still out.
Yeah, she came right away.
It took a lot of talking and coaxing and had the meetings and everything.
They would come to the meetings.
Some of them were coming because it was night and they thought nobody knew they were there.
They were coming.
And they saw everybody else voting and they just sat and come on out.
So you got a lot of people registered and then it was time to start planning for elections.
I was reading and Sue's book.
You were very active in a 1966 election for congressional races.
Mr. Hayes running here.
What did you do to mobilize people for that election?
We had different, like we had a lot of people that had a car to agree to, you know, we give gas to them.
That's traveling.
We agreed to pick up people that needed.
We had people posted at the center.
They could take calls when there were some people needing to be picked up.
And they called all over the county.
They were going and picking people up and getting them to the polls and waiting and taking them back home and everything.
But we had to let them know a head of time, you know, that we had transportation available to them.
And we had to have somebody for each area to find out how many people there needed to go and how many were willing to go.
Because most of them were afraid so you had to go and get them.
They wouldn't just come.
Some people made a way of calling.
But they didn't, they were afraid to come on their own.
So we had to make sure that they knew that we were with them and we were coming to pick them up.
And I should have pointed out that this was all under the offices of the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party.
It was not, you were not part of the right-winged Democratic Party.
Talk about your early work with the Freedom Democrats.
We had different people in the county and different parts of the county.
They were in charge of their area.
And the people in the community just knew who to get in touch with.
They were like, they called in.
They were telling you to tell them who they could get in touch with and who was being able to that day.
And before we had all kinds of meetings all across the county telling them who we were going to do and where we were going to be.
And who was going to do what?
So we had to get organized for that just like the real Democratic Party.
We had people all over the county and then placed for people to get information from to know what to do and everything.
And then take them to the polling places and let them know that these people, someone would even be afraid to go and say what they wanted to do.
Which you had to go and just talk for them.
For someone who had to speak for all of them.
In those early elections, was there intimidation at the polls?
Oh yes.
I had an instance where this guy wanted to...
His wife had never worked at the polls and I was the manager.
And the receiving and the returning manager.
And the chance to be cleared.
Then the circuit clerk, that's the world to care about more.
He had agreed to let this woman work in the position that I had had before.
And then he called me at home one night to tell me that he expected me to do what I had been doing all the time because she was new and she wouldn't know.
And I asked him who was going to be caring that title and be responsible for the election.
He said she was and I said, well all right, that's what she would be doing.
So I won't be doing it. She would be doing it.
So he came down that day.
And because she told him that she couldn't do it.
She didn't understand that she couldn't do it. She would rather not.
I also was put back in that position to be in receiving and returning and men.
And that even in her home was a truck drive.
He had a big log truck that even he came and somebody told him that his wife would work in that position.
So he came out there. He had been drinking and he was cursing everybody out.
He was just going to take her out and take her home and she wouldn't ever come back down that game.
So he had gone and everything. But some of our people came in and got him out of there.
And he got caught.
It was a little kind of scary at first though. He was the only one who got gone in there.
And he was crazy because he was drunk.
And he came and took it out of there.
And she couldn't help us to close the election.
I remember back then we had old buildings.
We had to vote in.
And sometimes the heat wasn't good.
It would be so cold in there.
And we have stayed there from then we went in at 6.30.
And we had to tell three and four o'clock that next morning we had to count them through the talent.
And that was rough.
We had to stick it out.
There were several of us.
And the other people would come in just to be there for support.
They could stand around. They just couldn't in the field with the elections.
I would bring in the community that would come out because it would be some of them there and some of us.
And it would be rough.
I remember well from my own experience and from others that on an election day,
why very often really rough looking white people with park themselves right in front of the door.
I wouldn't say anything they just sit there.
I was doing some full watching in Canton and cars with black families,
with black boards with cars.
And they'd see these guys and they'd turn off and go away.
That's what they were doing.
When time came for you to do the talent, they would come and stand right.
They could be able to observe you looking over your shoulder and everything.
So they would come and they wouldn't see anything.
But they would just come and act like we would.
When you had voters who had trouble reading, how did you handle that?
Were you able to go into the polling booth with them?
Yes.
How were they able to catch their vote the way they wanted to?
We had to make sure they knew that there were people there that they could ask for help.
That we couldn't just come and do and help them.
But there were people there that they could ask for help.
It got so many people would ask me to help them.
The other side started saying that I didn't want me to work at the polls.
They were thinking I was doing something because I would everybody knows to ask me.
But see, that was just the communication we had before.
You had to really be set up.
They would.
They would say, I can't do this.
I don't understand.
And they just, someone would come out of it.
They would come in and I would really forget they later came and she had, when she came in the door, she had asked for me.
They would want to know what she was wondering with me and who I was.
She was asking for a poll and she said, whether they had trouble.
She said, I was told that she could help me.
I don't know how to vote.
She can help me.
So this white guy, the name of Bob and Liz, he told she couldn't vote that day.
She didn't know how she couldn't vote.
And so one of the poll voices happened here.
So he brought over that and told them.
He got real upset.
And the lady, his wife worked at the welfare office.
And the lady was getting food stamps and welfare check.
They cut her house to her because it's all benefit.
And she could get it straight now.
In 1966 elections were sort of a warm up for the 67 elections.
And this is if the off-year elections over all the local officials and state legislators are elected.
And this was a very big time in the Holmes County.
Robert Clark was running for the state legislature.
Tell us about Mr. Clark and why he was a good candidate and they saw why.
He was well known all over the county.
And he had been a school teacher before that.
And he had gone around and did all of his campaign and then everything.
And everybody knew him.
And it was kind of where everybody knew what they was going to do when they went out there.
They tried everything to scare people back.
They had people out there working for them, the white folks,
saying telling them people what's going to happen if they went out and tried to vote for Representative Clark.
And there was a lot of people who would come back and report what they had said to them.
So by us having somebody stationed at every place outside and inside,
we had people out there that would be there to assist anybody that had trouble.
They would make sure, because if a person coming up to vote, they wouldn't know who was who.
They would even have some black people out there working for them.
So we had to try to make sure that they knew that we were there and they even helped them.
So it had gotten by then so that people knew what they was going to do with before they left home.
And that's how we were successful in this area all the time,
because people would always, if they knew that an election was coming up,
they would call, either me or somebody else, to find out what candidates we support,
and what are we doing now?
Where is the day and where do we go?
They would call and get all that information.
And then we would tell that person, tell your neighbor, tell your sister, your brother,
so they can know what to do when they get there.
That was some of the ways that we always were able to do the word of mouth thing,
and we couldn't count on getting to everybody, but we knew,
we would always know somebody that knew the next person,
and they would make sure they knew what to do.
Lauren Skiyot and his prepist, the soldier of his book,
was talking about Holmes County as being the best organized county in the state.
And there were a number of other counties with black majorities,
but in that election in 1967, the election of Robert Clark was the only successful legislative race,
and Clark became the first African American to sit in the state legislature in the 20th century.
Was there a big party after that election?
Yes, all over the county state,
people who ate yesterday were really proud.
It made us, Robert Clark was, whatever,
we're going on in the county.
If Robert Clark approved it, we knew that's what we needed to do.
We're going to, I would like them to look now at your professional career in Headstart,
and talk about CDGM and how you got involved and how that operated.
Well, CDGM and Sue and Hennie brought this to us also.
The state had got funded for six weeks, and we had to get the people they wanted to work,
and get a committee and everything to sit up for the center.
And Mileston was the only center that, in that five, six week program,
and we went down to Mount Bueblah, places.
It was necessary for a week when we stayed there and got trained on what the government expected of us with that program.
And it turned out just great.
Everything worked out well.
We thought we had it for just as long as we needed it.
It was really a good program.
I remember Polly Greenberg and Tom Levin,
and we were along with the chairperson for our center.
I was a secretary and I was also an assistant teacher.
So we had to drive to Jackson, like every Friday.
Like this Friday we carried the payroll and all the information to get what we needed for the center's operation of the center.
And we'll take the paperwork down there.
The next week we go and pick the checks up, and we had an account and a bank in Tchula,
And in the beginning, the bank refused to cash out checks.
They said they didn't know what it was. They had never heard of it.
And the only way we got checks was cash.
That was a supermarket in Tula.
They were cashed out checks, but they wouldn't even cash the checks.
The banks come around.
They came around as a guy that had a supermarket, a blue hotel.
He finally talked them into it.
And I remember there was another guy's name with DC Cohen.
They were talking about how was the fine going to come to us.
And they wanted us to get committed.
They'd then be over the fine and part of the program.
And we refused that night to do that.
And the club probably won't tell you all about it.
So I let him do it.
When we had that meeting that night, he thought I was from outside of Mississippi.
I was asking some questions.
But he'll tell you that he'd love to do that himself.
But anyway, there was a guy that has a store in Lexington, a track list.
So his name is Cohen.
I remember him and Hayes and Brandon Smith.
They had been in the meeting with us.
They were just doing what they wanted us to do.
And they were talking.
We were walking down the stairs.
I was kind of right behind them.
And they said, you know, he's niggas going suffer because they don't know what they're doing.
They can't handle a minor like that.
And I remember Cohen saying, they hurt my feeling, but it was true.
He said, you know Hayes and Nathan niggas alone say, my motto is give them anything they ask you for.
Bring me back and give me back to you the next day.
I said, well, I see that.
Well, they gone suffer for it because they could have had this money.
They won't get it.
And I told them she was kind of, you know, she was here.
And then to us, the other she talked to us and she was printing everything.
He's a man.
Hayes and Brandon Smith.
So I told him, I said, I said, miss Smith.
I said, one thing about it, we're used to suffer.
And I know some people that's not used to this.
So that's who it's going to hurt.
And she didn't say anything else.
We kept walking.
But anyway, it was rough that first year they wouldn't, every time that,
we'd come in, the government would veto it.
And then they would have to override them to get the money.
So that's more time.
And therefore, I remember at the end of those six weeks, they didn't tell us anything.
When I knew anything, we knew anything at the center where I were.
But they were coming in to get all the furniture and everything out.
They'd give them the chairs and tables and everything.
And they said there was something, miss Smith, something I don't know what it was.
But anyway, we started working right away on trying to get, get refunded.
I'm going to stop right here because of that.
But we should know that CDGM was voted as the best head start program in the country that summer.
And tell us what it was like to be working in that center about the kids, about the program for the day.
It was wonderful that we had.
The final money was enough so that everything you needed to operate was called.
They had food like you would get at a restaurant.
They had steaks, pork chops, sauces and eggs and everything for breakfast and lunch and everything.
If someone came there at three o'clock, they would steal some food that you could see.
Sometimes the people from Jackson will come and they will come and eat.
But we had everything we had been using equipment and stuff that the farmers, different carpenter's, deals for.
We got everything we needed in the chair.
It was so beautiful to cheer.
What about teaching?
We were trying to teach them just like regular.
When first we had to get them used to coming out and being away from home and for me and people.
I remember the first group we had a shower in the center and some of the children would come and pick them up out of the bed and make clothes for them.
We had to get in the shower with them.
We could get in the shower with the children and bathe them in the shower.
They had never seen a shower.
Some of them never seen commos in the bathroom before.
They had outside toys.
We would teach the children.
We started out. We would teach them.
We did this even before we had money.
We would teach them about letting them tell us things about that they knew.
We would write it down.
We would read it back to them.
It would be like, thank Father Greenberg, we had a book.
She wrote about some things that we did like that.
We taught them how to use the taught and how to bathe themselves.
We taught them how to share with other children.
We taught them how to speak.
They had been there for the first two weeks.
It was like they didn't want to go home in the evening.
They were just so proud of being there.
When we had the first little graduation, we were so proud that they had learned.
Some of the teachers came from the school and they couldn't believe that those children had learned.
They were able to write their names.
They could print their names.
They could recognize every child in the class and recognize their names.
We had cards for the children with their names on.
We had a chair.
We were practicing with them and getting everybody's chair.
They had a name you called.
They could go and find that chair.
They could find the colors of all the chairs with different colors.
The tables, some of them with different colors.
That's how we taught what we had, whatever we had.
We would go outside and let the children find things outside.
They would count the cards.
They would count the bills.
They would count the trees, the flowers, and everything.
That taught them so much.
Some of the parents didn't know some of those things.
They teach their children.
That's why they didn't know.
I learned a lot of that to you myself.
That's how children learn.
They learn whatever their environment is.
You could see how the children was progressing.
It was so hurt for when they said,
the money was gone, we could not get fond of it.
We started working on it.
I just asked about that.
The CDGM, although it was the best program in the country,
was not refunded because Senator John (Senator John) Stennis and others believed
that it was a civil rights order.
That's what they say.
The money coming into the state, they couldn't make it.
What happened here when you found that no longer,
there was temporary funding for a while,
and then they cut it off completely.
How did that start evolve through all this?
We didn't lose count again, Mileston.
We started working all over again just like the movement.
We started working, getting people together and trying to,
we even got a bus, my second dollar,
and three other children and one of our teachers,
the name Zellma, she lived in Cleveland.
They went to Washington to live with our funds for Head Start.
We all got together and rented a greyhound bus for the state.
Everybody sent, how many children they wanted to,
they went to the city for that trip.
I was always stuck in the center keeping it.
That was a water look.
Yes, it was.
You turned those kids loose on a congressman.
Yes, that's what we did.
After that, we worked for three months without funds again.
We brought the food out.
We worked just like when we had to be kept in the program going
just like when we had fun.
We worked until May of the next year,
and finally got fun and again.
Tell us about it.
Well, we kept you long enough,
but I want you to talk about what you've been doing
in the years since the movement years.
Well, I've gone to college.
Where did you go to college?
To (Tougaloo) the (one in) the Delta.
It was such a long time ago.
I had gone and got a two-year degree first,
and I'm thinking, you know,
before we all had to have a high school certificate
to work with you, sorry.
But every time they changed, we had to keep going.
And finally, I got a CDA credential.
And then a couple of years ago,
they said we had to go back to school.
So I had been going that time,
but I had to, I had a chair that had to go to school first.
So I had to let them go.
And when they got finished, I started back.
And then my health started kind of failing.
I'm a diabetic, I typed through that bit.
So it was a little much for me, and I stopped.
But then this, I had,
I only needed about three hours to graduate,
but I just had kept putting it off.
And finally, I went back down there,
and I met Dr. McLean.
And he told me,
now he was in 78 when I got my two-year degree.
And he was saying, he wasn't sure if the college would accept everything I had,
but they had a way that they could have me to brush up on some of them.
And that's what we're doing now.
But I kept, I kept all,
I've been working at his side for the seven years now.
Wow. That is amazing.
I'm still there.
Thank you so much for sharing your story with us.
This was inspirational.
I know the people who read the transcript
and watch this at the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture
will be as excited as we are here to have you tell the story.
Wow. That is right.
You nailed it.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.